our principles for how to solve this
problem are a couple so one so like
naming an identity this is the type of
thing that's like a public utility like
nobody should own the the naming system
of the internet so this is true of dns
actually so like dns itself um the core
part of it is a you know non-profit open
uh protocol of the internet uh there are
companies that then have the consumer
facing side um and so they have this
interesting hybrid model um but dns
itself uh you know it's just like a
neutral protocol of the internet so we
think that still holds true here and
that has really informed
how we've gone about doing enos i can
talk more about that in a second
another key principle is that the
internet already has a naming system so
with dns you know there wasn't really a
widely used thing when it was started it
was new but now we do and so uh we think
it's best for users and best for the
success of the technology if we try to
remain as compatible um with the
existing name space for as long as
possible
so like ens we're not trying to like
replace dns anytime you know dns for
what it does it does it really well okay
right but we we want to complement
uh and expand it of new capabilities and
to kind of
bring the internet to this new
decentralized blockchain future but with
as few collisions and problems as
possible when it comes to the simplified
payments uh use case of vns it can
support any or any arbitrary asset uh so
this this does confuse a lot of people
uh they think you can only send ethereum
ether or ethereum based assets uh no you
can send uh receive bitcoin to a name
you know solana solana nft uh dogecoin
so what this means is actually like you
can send dogecoin to bcmilligan.com
and it's using ens on ethereum in the
background it's actually much simpler
than people think so a lot of people
think that like if i send let's say
ether to brantley.edu that like i'm
sending it to the name and that like ens
receives it and forwards it on to you or
something it's actually much simpler
than that ens is ultimately just names
and like data attached to those names so
i can store any arbitrary data i could
store a bitcoin address and a theorem
address to laundress i can store my
favorite type of dog i can store my
phone number anything you want
and then when i type in that name let's
say in a wall let's say trustwall like
i'm saying doge i say send this to
bcmilling.com what they do is it looks
at bcmilgan.com on ens on ethereum gras
you know since based on context it knows
i'm sending dogecoin so it grabs the
dogecoin address in my records it brings
that back to the wallet and then the
wallet just sends it like a normal
dogecoin transaction on the dogecoin
network but that just happens all in the
background uh from the user's
perspective like you're sending doge to
bcmilligan.com uh but that's what's
happening in the background the
information's entirely on chains
entirely essential i mean this is really
critical to the whole vision of ens that
like if the the primary team developing
if we all died nothing stops nothing
nothing has hurt enos continues to go on
i hope people would mourn my death but
um ens would continue to go on no
problem because literally we're running
no infrastructure this really confuses a
lot of people so um and that's a key
thing on this identity thing i want to
say is that okay this has been happening
in web 3 for a while of people you sign
in with your private key uh use your ens
name and things like this for your
identity but it all been just like
organically done with no standards and
some people were doing good practices
and some people are doing bad practices
right um so the ethereum foundation and
ens we teamed up earlier this year and
we had an rfp request for proposals
basically saying hey we want to find
somebody who can like standardize what's
currently being done just with best
practices we selected this company
called uh spruce id in the last few
months they've been leading this open
community um
process uh to basically write an eip
that's the ethereum standards process uh
ethereum improvement proposal it's like
bips right
and uh that's almost done basically to
standardize this and we call it signing
with ethereum so it's best practices
here's exactly the message you should
have people sign they have like a
javascript library they have like an
oauth implementation you know you can
use if you want
and so you sign with your private key
uses your ens same as your username uses
your avatar from the records uses any
other profile data and i think the cool
thing about this is that this works not
just for crypto services we've designed
it so that non-crypto services can
easily add this as an authentication
option so like you're signing into some
other random non-crypto service they
have like sign in with email uh sign in
with google something with facebook well
we've made this so they can just drop
into those options signed with ethereum
as one of those options